THE RULES COMMITTEE FOR THERAPY
A PORTRAIT FUTURE FACULTY ORDER.
COPIES VIETNAM ADVISE IN AUDIO
AND VIDEO ACCORDING TO THESE
PROCEEDINGS. ME AS ALSO BEING
TELEVISED.
MADAM SECRETARY WHO PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL COOLEY HERE CUNNINGHAM
HERE CARILLO. TORONTO HERE.
FRIEDMAN GALLAGHER COOLEY AYE
COOLEY AYE
CUNNINGHAM FIVE CUNNINGHAM AYE
CARILLO. CARILLO AYE CERVANTES.
SURVIVED AS I FRIEDMAN GALLAGHER
GRAYSON AYE GRAYSON AYE MAYES.
MAYES I KNOWS AREA SOLACE I
SOLIS AYE WALDRON ON WATER AND
I'VE.
CLOSENESS PASS AND.
I DO WANT TO KNOW LOOKS WELCOME.
TO RAISE THIS AUGUST COMMITTEE.
DELIGHTED TO HAVE YOU.
AND.
WITH THAT THIS MEETING IS
ADJOURNED